mit jedem Tritt kommt Ellen seinem Ziel
näher seinem Tageslohn wir sind neun
Autostunden von Manila entfernt früher
verbannt diese Bahnstrecke die südlichen
Provinzen mit der Hauptstadt seit fast
20 Jahren fährt hier kein Zug mehr doch
die Schienen bleiben die
Hauptverkehrsader mit selbstgebauten
Wagen und Muskelkraft
anschieben und Geld verdienen drei bis
fünf Euro macht Ellen pro Tag mit seinem
schienentaxi obwohl er lieber zur Schule
gehen würde
[Musik]
wenn wir nichts mehr zu essen haben gehe
ich nicht hier zur Schule sondern
arbeite auf den Schienen damit wir Reis
kaufen können
die corona-pandemie hat den Alltag hier
verändert Fischerei kokosnussernte alles
gegen zurück viele haben ihren Job
verloren der 17-Jährige Ellen muss
seitdem noch mehr mit anpacken und seine
Schule war zwei Jahre lang geschlossen
[Musik]
ich hatte ganz schön Probleme beim
Lernen weil wir nur Hausaufgaben bekamen
und niemand die Fragen erklärte die zwei
pandemiejahre waren wirklich schwierig
[Musik]
zwei Jahre lang in kaum einem Land fiel
der Präsenzunterricht so lange aus wie
auf den Philippinen
auch Mary Joy war glücklich als sie
endlich zurück in die Schule durfte
sie will selbst Lehrerin werden doch sie
hat viel nachzuholen aus der Zeit in der
sie alleine lernen musste
vor allem in Mathe und Englisch merkt
sie das
bildung ist wichtig ich will lernen ich
muss die Schule beenden damit ich in der
Lage bin meiner Mutter und meinem Vater
etwas zurückzuzahlen
es gibt Tage an denen mein Vater sehr
müde ist aber er macht trotzdem alles
für uns
[Musik]
die corona-maßnahmen auf den Philippinen
waren streng monatelang durften Menschen
unter 18 oder über 65 das Haus nur im
Notfall verlassen
Mary Joyce Vater holte ihre
Aufgabenblätter in der Schule ab sie
versuchte sie alleine zu lösen ohne
Lehrer ohne Internet ohne Handy ohne
Kontakt zu Mitschülern
Lehrer samboy weiß um diese Probleme und
tut etwas dagegen als die Kinder nicht
mehr zur Schule kommen durften brachte
er die Schule zu Ihnen und auch seit
wieder normaler Unterricht stattfindet
schaffen es längst nicht alle regelmäßig
zu kommen und deshalb macht er weiter
bevor er uns das zeigt nimmt er uns mit
zum Markt hier kauft der 28-Jährige
alles was er braucht für den typisch
philippinischen schokoreisbrei
[Musik]
es ist einfacher die Kinder zu
unterrichten wenn Sie einen vollen Magen
haben damit sie mehr lernen können
deshalb ist der schokobrei in samboys
Schule genauso wichtig wie Bücher und
Lehrer
seit die normale Schule wieder geöffnet
hat fährt die schienenschule am
Wochenende in die Dörfer
die Pandemie hat das Bildungsproblem auf
den Philippinen noch verstärkt lange
Schulwege schlecht ausgestattete Schulen
Kinder die Arbeiten statt rechnen oder
schreiben zu lernen
statt anschieben und Geld verdienen
heißt es hier anschieben und lesen
[Musik]
wenn alle satt sind beginnt der
Unterricht
[Musik]
die meisten Kinder hier sind sehr arm
und können deshalb nicht zur Schule
gehen
die Pandemie hat die Armut hier noch
vergrößert viele auch ganz kleine sind
inzwischen fast eingeplant um zum
Familieneinkommen beizutragen sie müssen
arbeiten
die schienenschule lebt von Spenden und
vor allem vom persönlichen Einsatz
samboys
ältere Schülerinnen und Schüler sind
Hilfslehrer zum Beispiel car iron der
17-Jährige hat die schienenschule
entworfen
später will er Architekt werden er weiß
wie schwierig lernen ohne Lehrer ist
ich bin so daran gewöhnt den ganzen Tag
am Handy zu sein jetzt freue ich mich
darauf diese Kinder zu unterrichten auf
dieses Erfolgserlebnis anderen zu helfen
samboy ist stolz auf seinen Lehrer
Nachwuchs die jüngeren Kinder
profitieren von dem Wissen der älteren
Schülerinnen und Schüler
[Musik]
es ist ein Leben zwischen Arbeit und
Schule zwischen Armut und Hoffnung und
jeder Tag ist eine neue Herausforderung
ich suche nach Muscheln damit wir was
zum Essen haben
[Musik]
auf der einen Seite das Meer auf der
anderen die Kokospalmen unter zwischen
die Schienen
samboy ist selbst direkt neben den
Gleisen aufgewachsen er kennt dieses
Leben aus eigener Erfahrung
[Musik]
es tut mir weh die Kinder so zu sehen
als ich ein Kind war habe ich dasselbe
getan
ich habe alles getan was nötig war um
meiner Familie zu helfen
er hatte Unterstützung von einer
Lehrerin die ihn gefördert hat auch wenn
der Unterricht längst zu Ende war
in der schienenschule will er das an
seine Schülerinnen und Schüler
weitergeben
[Musik]